[Music]
[Applause]
it's over the top just like the movie is
it's completely indulgent hey what's up
everybody I'm Jonathan Bennett aka Aaron
Samuels and I am so excited because
today we're gonna be making a recipe for
my new parody cookbook for Mean Girls
fans the Byrne cookbook
you guys ready to melt check it like
2004 so obviously Mean Girls was my
first movie and I'm so honored to be a
part of it and after Mean Girls I went
on to host a bunch of food competition
shows like cake wars and Halloween wars
and it was awesome and then I realized I
need to marry my love for food with my
love for pop culture I thought why not
make an amazing book where people can
come together make the food watch the
movie and relive some of their favorite
moments with some of their best friends
and sometimes we all need a partner in
crime just to make sure we're doing
everything right so I teamed up with my
favorite chef Nikki Martin to help me
write the book Nikki get in loser it's
dessert we're making a milkshake if I
was a plastic I would definitely be
Lindsay Lohan not like Lindsay Lohan's
character I just want to be Lila it's
fun being part of pop culture and being
Aaron Samuels and for a lot of years I
didn't like it but what happened was
when my dad got sick we went to a
restaurant and he had these girls come
and take a photo with me and I was like
dad do we have to take photos all the
time and he goes when was the last time
you saw people that happen
all these girls like looking at the
pictures and they're giggling and like
one calling her mom and she's like shaky
and she's crying and that's when I
realized that Mean Girls is more than
just a movie it's part of their life and
so like I decided to just lean into it
it's an honor to be a part of people's
lives it's the milk shake that you want
to make with your friends push the
coffee table out of the way and get
right in the middle of the living room
and do the little Kylie George dance and
watch the movie and dance in your living
room I mean you know all the moves to
the Jingle Bell Rock
and Nikki what do you think did we do a
good job I think we crushed it
oh yeah let's say so alright yup you
need this help shake em up
[Music]
you
[Music]